Hello, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters just answering some questions that you have said to him. This one about Dave programs
This person says there are two programs on my son's cancer daily file
Do we mix those with
In randomly at night or we do those during the day, so don't if that I had not done this with everybody
So don't get flustered if you go well. I don't have any day programs
But some people I put some short day programs in their file as well
Those are to be used during the day
So not at night use your night programs at night for short programs
Rundering the day when you can or when you have a chance when you're sitting studying you're reading a book
You're watching TV and I always say it's really good to kind of set up your hole in a way that when you do have
Down time that you usually maybe read a book or you'd like to watch a program or something like that
That you set it up where you can run the right while you're doing that
You know when you're ambulatory out and about you can't be running to your right
So but when you're relaxed sitting try to create a space a safe space that you can do that
Um and run the right at the same time run the day programs if I didn't create day program programs for you run your night program
At that time will I my night program is nine hours and I'm only sit there for half an hour
That's okay. Just write it for half an hour then you can just
Stop it if you're gonna get up and not come back
So um, so run that day program during the day if you're if you're gonna just rest
Second after this question how many immune stimulation
Programs can I do in a day how many programs overall could I do in a day?
Literally you could run the right 24-7
I don't want you to run the right 24-7 if you're a healthy ambulatory person because I want you out live in your life
But certainly if you're not feeling well, you should be running the right
There is no limit you can't like hurt yourself with the right
Unless you have live disease
But you're ready to kill program said you could cause a hurt cyber reaction, but that's a totally different story with cancer
Something that we're dealing with here you can't hurt yourself run your programs
So don't feel bad about it. Hey, I want to run multiple immune stimulation programs during the day
But all needs to do that any other programs as well to make sure you're getting your overnight programs in overnight at least
So again if you have other questions, please send them in some of them will make little short videos on some will get into
The zoom call. All right. Thanks so much